welcome to Groundhog Day America the
speaker's stalemate on Capitol Hill
showing no signs of stopping and it's
unclear who will blink first Republicans
are locked in a fierce battle over who
should hold the gavel the house taking a
break until 8 PM after Kevin McCarthy
lost his sixth vote for speaker
Republicans backing him say enough with
the nonsense it's time to move forward
so they can go after Joe Biden
this 20 has gotten together and decided
that they can only blackmail the
Republican conference in effect they're
blackmailing the American people there's
headlines about the chaos this and that
yesterday our colleagues on the other
side of the aisle were tweeting their
bags of popcorn that they had out they
love it I plead with all
all of my Republican colleagues
let cooler more rational heads prevail
I've had a number of conversations with
Kevin and just basically told him that
at some point this needs to break loose
he either needs to make a deal or he
needs to step aside and give somebody
else a chance to do that but the 20-plus
Republicans who oppose Kevin McCarthy
aren't giving up
I think the path is very difficult right
now for Kevin but the core of this is
yes we were successful in taking back
the majority but we still have to deal
with the realities of governing here in
Washington and a one-day delay or a
two-day delay even a three-day delay
does not stop us from being able to do
the things that we were elected to do
and the Democrats smell an opportunity
AOC thinks the Republican infighting
could potentially open the door for her
party to gain some extra power
is there anyone in their caucus that can
build that consensus if there isn't uh
McCarthy's team may have to come to the
Democratic party and if that's the case
then what would that even look like
could we get
Democratic chairs of committees as a
result if he chooses to approach the
Democratic caucus then that would be a
negotiation in and of itself or
potential coalition government
okay Greg I'll start with you on this
political issue well first uh I haven't
asked the question I don't need a
question I already have my strong
feelings this is not Groundhog Day at
all it's the opposite of Groundhog Day
because in the movie he actually got
better remember every day this is the
opposite he's not no one's learning
anything it's anti-grant Groundhog Day
poor Kevin McCarthy he's lost more
ballots than a democratic poll worker
so sue me anyway uh I'm starting to
change my mind on this I want it to go
on forever it's like an Extra Inning
game that like when it's on you go it's
at the 22nd inning you wanted to go to
27 you want to go to how long could this
go it's like a a horrifying spectacle
but it's also it's also hypnotic and
everybody says oh you know dem uh what
is it democracy is messy oh stop it it's
everybody knows this is just a pain the
but I love how the Democrats act like
this is some kind of catastrophe
maybe but it's self-contained right it's
self-contained it's not affecting
Americans the you know the way
Afghanistan or the Border or inflation
so at least you know when Republicans
have a firing squad it's circular but
the Democrats shoot everybody so I like
that I like that and I mean here's my my
last point I have a theory that this is
all being done uh because it's like they
they love to revert to being college
kids pulling an all-nighter so this is
just an excuse to order 50 pizzas and
make us pay for it oh well that
certainly explains it thank you Greg
Dana how long do you how long do you
think McCarthy stays on look he's been
voted he hasn't been able to get to 218
in six votes and Victoria Sparks now is
voting present twice she says she's
doing that because she wants a
discussion she so why do they just keep
voting do they think that God's going to
come down and say everybody change your
vote and he was and she was quite close
with Kevin McCarthy and so that one's
got to hurt but I think you know Ken
Buck us also heard him say you know at
some point guys we have to do something
it's not the end of the world it's not
the end of democracy it's been two days
and it could go for a few more but it
probably won't I think today there was
no movement towards Kevin McCarthy there
was a slight movement back so they're a
little bit out of stalemate so I think
the other thing that's happening is that
the name calling is getting ratcheted up
within the party and they are going to
get through this there will be a speaker
at some point and then they're all going
to have to work together and they're
saying a lot of things that are going to
be very difficult to forget and hard to
forgive so I think there's only one
solution that they should do tonight
which is drunk get drunk yes yeah
everybody needs to go to the bar and it
needs the open bar and they need to all
get drunk and they have a moment because
that's what you do with a team when
you're having a little bit of a problem
I'm not saying look actually yes I am
saying go get drunk and just like
check the phones at the door no one can
take a phone in and everyone just have a
chance to talk about something Trump in
his statement today said why are you
giving up this opportunity to celebrate
you got back the majority and you're
blowing it guys and I thought he had a
good point the last thing I wanted to
mention is I feel like they're
forgetting these lessons that happened
during the Boehner and Paul Ryan years
which is if you don't give your team the
votes then whoever the speaker is going
to be and that might not be McCarthy
maybe it's somebody else at that point
let's say it's the debt ceiling if you
don't have the votes of your team then
you're going to have to go get them
somewhere else for like must pass
legislation where do you get them well
from moderate Democrats what does that
do that opens up the legislation to
allow Democrats to change things to
their will which makes the outliers even
more mad and then they can point to them
and say you're so establishment it's not
good a good exercise and the other thing
is they're missing this opportunity
today what did Biden announce under the
cover of all of this his intention is to
go to the Border after the Republicans
have been saying he needed to go for two
years now who's going to talk about that
in the morning no one because they're
going to talk about this it does just
getting drunk does McCarthy in order to
get 218 votes does he try to build a
coalition with moderate Democrats by
turning to the Democrats and if he does
succeed that a lot of people hurt their
careers
if he cuts a deal with the Democrats
he's toast because then he has to give
Democrats something
and you can never give Democrats
anything
politics is tough you get this close to
power and your own team kicks you in the
groin six times in the groin
I hate this because I don't like talking
about Republican infighting I have a
personal policy not to get involved in
Republican primary battles
so I say this under duress
but I feel like this is all my fault
because I've been calling
Kevin McCarthy speaker on prime time for
about three months
I jinxed it
I don't know if he's dead yet but he's
close because
I've never seen a situation where
someone takes someone hostage and their
main demand is I want the hostage dead
yeah
so the hostage has to commit suicide yep
it doesn't really I don't know how if
you survive is someone else gonna go
some of me thinks this is personal like
Gates doesn't like him because he didn't
back him when the Department of Justice
hung that case over his head right but
then I listened to chip Roy on Laura
Ingram last night and Chip Roy said this
is what they don't want they don't want
every Christmas week to the Senate shove
trillions of dollars of spending down
their throats and say you have 24 hours
to vote Yes on this or Christmas is over
and so they want to be on the rules
committee so does he have to give these
guys the rules committee give the
freedoms the rules committee is that
what more do they want I feel like they
could he could give the freedoms
everything and they want to scalp
instead so I don't know and Greg nailed
it yesterday I'm with Greg on this
wake me up when they land the plane yeah
I don't care if it crashes I don't care
if it lands wake me up when something
happens because they're ready to do so
the founders were smart though he's like
you got to sit in the room together
we're gonna lock the door you're not
coming out until you guys decide but I
don't feel like I have to be in the
smoke-filled room why do I have to feel
like I'm in the room and think about it
back then they really smelled bad right
now and now I'm getting the stink on me
yes okay you know what there's a tweet
by Corey Bush I want you to take a look
at it Jessica uh she was two uh
African-Americans were suggested for
speaker on the Democrat side Hakeem
Jeffries Republican Byron Donalds and of
course Corey Bush comes out she says
it's not historic candidate uh Byron is
not a historic candidate for speaker
he's a prop despite being black he
supports a policy agenda intent on
upholding and perpetuating white
supremacy
what do you think of that
it's not very nice
I have
talked a lot about people supporting
policies that I do not think is in their
best interest whether it's women people
of color other dis traditionally
disadvantaged groups obviously that
doesn't help and and Corey Bush I think
has really supplanted AOC as the biggest
thorn in the Democrat side and all of
this AOC has really gotten in line you
notice even how she conducts herself in
interviews the people that she talks to
I mean I've seen from the coverage of
what's going on the floor she's talking
to more Republicans than almost any
other Democratic member of the house
right it's not going particularly far
with Matt Gates or Paul gosar for
instance but
she's out there trying to figure out
some way that Democrats can maintain it
and how did Cory Bush say that
because she thinks that he's an Uncle
Tom did she think that if you're a black
person who supports a Republican party
that it strips away your Blackness
because Republican policies do not to in
Cory Bush's mind do not benefit people
of color that's what it is
it's a stunt right now it's obviously
incredibly unuseful I'm sure Hakeem
Jeffries is not happy about this
conversation going on the side he has a
completely unified caucus shows up every
day 212 votes 212 votes 212 votes and
then there's something like this that's
a distraction to all of it so I
it's not useful okay all right everyone
I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now